[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 politique sur tv fil 78 chaque
mercredi une nouvelle édition pour
suivre au mieux la campagne des
législatives dans notre département des
yvelines aujourd'hui deux invités dans
un instant le candidat investi notamment
par europe écologie les verts sur la 10e
circonscription david jutier et puis
déjà en plateau françois xavier bellamy
bonjour vous êtes le candidat soutenu
par les républicains sur la première
circonscription alors avant de parler de
votre candidature peut être une réaction
suite à la victoire elle d'emmanuel
macron est ce que vous étiez de ceux qui
avaient appelé le soutenir à voter pour
lui pendant l'entre-deux-tours pendant
l'entre-deux-tours jeu j'ai fait
confiance au discernement de tous les
français et je crois que nous les élus
nous devons être très humble et très
modeste et et regarder les échéances
électorales qui se présentent en mettant
à la place de tous les français qui ont
un choix à faire j'ai fait un choix bien
sûr mais je n'ai pas appelé à voter pour
emmanuel macron dans notre équipe
municipale nous avons eu parfois des
positions un peu différente sur ce sujet
mais l'on dirait qu'ils ont tous été lus
à versailles effectivement départ
préciser exactement la fée discussions
on va y revenir sur ses résultats au
sein des au sein de versailles et puis
plus globalement peut-être déjà le
résultat au sein des yvelines on va
revoir ce résultat d' emmanuel macron
dans le département adhésives line
jusqu'à présent les républicains étaient
majoritaires dans les yvelines
au premier tour françois fillon était
derrière emmanuel macron emmanuel macron
elle qui fait même un meilleur score
vous le voyez qu au niveau national ici
dans le département est ce qu'il faut y
voir un signe est ce que ça vous
inquiète pour la campagne législative
selon les haltes à des manuels mâcon
dans le département au premier et au
second tour pas du tout je pense qu'on a
vécu une campagne présidentielle très
particulière et tous les observateurs
s'accorderont pour le reconnaître nous
avons vécu une campagne qui a été
profondément marquées par une succession
de péripéties d'affaires qui ont saturé
l'espace médiatique et qui nous ont au
fond et chacun le regrette et je pense
que quelles que soient nos sensibilités
politiques nous en sommes tous désolés
qui nous ont empêché de faire un vrai
choix autour d'un vrai projet et donc je
crois que la campagne des législatives
qui s'ouvre elle va être d'abord
passionnante et puis surtout elle va
avoir un enjeu majeur parce que cette
fois ci nous sommes débarrassés de ces
difficultés qui pesait sur une personne
et c'est vrai que nous allons pouvoir
dans une élection qui est moins
personnalisée et qui est plus lié à un
projet donné vraiment j'espère une
majorité à la france pour faire les
réformes dont elle a profondément besoin
ce qui a été terriblement frustrant dans
cette campagne des présidentielles c'est
que les grands sujets qui nous attendent
pour l'avenir la question de l'école la
question de la réforme du marché du
travail et la question de la fiscalité
la question de la dette la question de
l'écologie
ces grandes questions là nous en avons
trop peu parlé aujourd'hui il faut les
remettre sur la table et c'est ce que
j'espère pour cette campagne législative
qui commence donc vous espérez une
majorité droite sont majoritaires les
républicains ça veut dire une
cohabitation
ce que je crois c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
succès d' emmanuel macron est un succès
qui est lié à un choix massivement fait
par défaut et beaucoup de français même
à la sortie des urnes selon l'ond confié
le grand risque que je vois moi pour la
france c'est que la majorité qu'il tente
de constituer ne soit pas assez
cohérente pour porter des choix qui
seront nécessairement difficile exigeant
et qui appelle une véritable cohérence
et je crois que la droite dans cette
campagne a tenté de porter autant
qu'elle l'a pu son son projet
aujourd'hui si ce projet est capable de
susciter une majorité la droite peut
effectivement se mettre au service de
ses réformes dont la france a tellement
besoin
françois-xavier bellamy candidat dans la
première circonscription des yvelines
vous souhaitez conserver pour la droite
ce poste qui est aujourd'hui détenue par
le maire de versailles françois de
mazières avant de nous exposer vos
projets les images tout de même de cette
soirée est de victoires dont les
yvelines avec les militants dans marche
pour le second tour de la présidentielle
c'était le 7 mai au soir reportage
nicolas landry
[Applaudissements]
les premières estimations sont tombés
emmanuel macron vient d'être élu
président de la république
il obtient plus de 65 % des voix la fête
peut commencer pour les militants
yvelinois du mouvement en marche on est
euphorique
c'est génial c'est vraiment c'est pas
marine le pen qui bat c on a contré le
le fascisme entre guillemets on est
super content
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parti de rien il est devenu président
nouveau là je suis ravi de l'espoir qui
porte à 4 sur l'unité dans les yvelines
le candidat en marche on obtient plus de
77% des suffrages
un meilleur score qu'au niveau national
que l'on retrouve aussi à montigny le
bretonneux
avec près de 84% des voix de quoi
satisfaire les marcheurs pour leur
mobilisation
c'est très très fort ce qui a pu se
faire on a
travailler de figure mais surtout quand
je pense à tous ces bénévoles qui nous
ont suivi quand même des premiers jours
qui ont cru en nous et qui sont battus
partout aujourd'hui hier encore on était
sûr marché contre la jolie mais ce qu'a
réalisé emmanuel macron c'est justement
de permettre un pur français de revoir
en eau et de re croire dans cette belle
dame qui est la cinquième ribéry est
d'aller à l'assaut pour une révolution
démocratique
certains militants quittent rapidement
le qg yvelinois direction l'esplanade du
louvre pour célébrer ce moment inédite
dans l'histoire de la vème république un
candidat élu président en ayant créé son
mouvement politique il est un peu plus
d'un an
tout le monde nous disait que c'était
impossible
melvin ne connaissez pas la france
[Applaudissements]
merci de votre confiance
merci du temps que vous avez donnée
merci de votre engagement à toutes et
tous des remerciements destiné notamment
aux militants du modem
durant la campagne il se sont engagés
aux côtés d' emmanuel macron notamment
dans les yvelines
mais le soutien du modem reste plein et
entier au bien au contraire on est plus
motivé que jamais pour l'aider à réussir
son projet entre les candidats en marche
et des crocs d'un modèle sous la même
bannière
avant cette alliance pour les
législatives des postes ministériels
pourraient être attribués à des membres
du modem
emmanuel macron devrait dévoiler le nom
de son premier ministre et la
composition du gouvernement
lundi 15 mai le 7-8 politique se
poursuit et comme lors de chaque édition
dorénavant nous faisons le point sur
cette campagne des législatives premier
tour le 11 juin focus sur cette première
circonscription qui couvre versa et
guyancourt encore montigny le bretonneux
françois-xavier bellamy vous avez 31 non
vous êtes conseiller municipal à
versailles dans la majorité de françois
de mazières c'est d'ailleurs lui qui
vous a fait rentrer finalement en
politique en 2008 vous avez rejoint sa
liste divers droite et vous l'avez
emporté vous êtes devenu le plus jeune
adjoint au maire dans une grande ville
de france
qu'est ce qui vous a donné le goût à la
politique pour vous connaître un petit
peu mieux pour les téléspectateurs
j'étais pas j'étais pas prédisposé à
faire de la politique mon projet
professionnel a toujours été
l'enseignement et je suis aujourd'hui
encore à temps plein un professeur de
philosophie j'ai eu la chance
d'enseigner d'ailleurs sur notre sur
notre territoire d'être enseignant à
guyancourt au lycée hôtelier de
guyancourt c'est vraiment un métier qui
me passionne et je n'étais pas destiné à
la politique mais ce qui m'a fait
rentrer c'est vraiment c'est vraiment la
rencontre d'une personnalité françois de
mazières qui en 2008 m'a fait confiance
et et avec qui j'ai eu envie de
contribuer à la vie de la ville où
j'avais grandi de ce territoire que nous
aimons tant je crois que
nous avons aujourd'hui notamment parmi
la jeune génération une vraie
responsabilité pour prendre notre part
dans la construction la reconstruction
la refondation de notre pays et ça
commence évidemment par le terrain local
par l'engagement concret ces années pour
moi ont été passionnantes elles le sont
toujours et c'est vraiment dans cette
histoire d'équipé et de d'engagement
locale que s'inscrit mon propre
engagement politique
sur le plan idéologique justement vous
étiez impliqué dans la manif pour tous
au sein de sens commun également n'ont
jamais été j'ai jamais été dans ce sens
commun j'ai participé à la manif pour
tous comme comme des centaines de
milliers de français parce que je
croyais que la question du mariage est
une question fondamentale et notamment
la question de la filiation et cette
question là elle et elle et elle est
toujours décisive
aujourd'hui nous nous fêtons la
commémoration de l'esclavagé je crois
que nous devons être extrêmement
vigilants et attentifs sur la le risque
que nous pourrions faire peser par nono
nos progrès autoproclamé sur le risque
d'une instrumentalisation des corps
d'une marchandisation de la vie humaine
cette question là n'a rien à voir avec
l'homosexualité en la question de la gpa
de la pma touche aussi bien des couples
hétérosexuels mais c'est vrai que je
croyais que la loi du mariage pour tous
à lettres un cheval de troie de ces de
ces avancées qui n'en sont pas est ce si
c'est confirmé
donc j'ai mené ce combat mais beaucoup
d'autres si je me suis beaucoup engagé
sur la question de l'éducation qui me
paraît vraiment fondamental revenir sur
l'éducation mais sur l'oeuvre pour vous
situer sur l'échiquier politique ont
aussi tué ou au sein de la famille de la
droite à la droite de la droite où il ya
plusieurs tendances aujourd'hui au sein
des républicains qui sont exprimés je ne
serai pas trouvé pas de cette étiquette
peut-être ca je pense vraiment
profondément et d'ailleurs le succès d'
emmanuel macron est aussi un signe de
cela nous devons le regarder avec
beaucoup d'attention et d'intérêt
je pense profondément que la vie
politique française est aujourd'hui
écrasé sous le poids des étiquettes et
des clivages ce qui compte le plus c'est
de refaire des propositions qui
permettent aux gens de dialoguer
ensemble et je crois par exemple que
dans la campagne qui a été menée par la
droite
nous avons sans doute certainement
manqué de cette générosité de cette
attention qui sont difficiles à
cataloguer qui n'appartiennent pas à une
étiquette particulière mais mais
qui ont certainement manqué de dans
notre rapport notamment aux plus petits
aux plus fragiles aux plus vulnérables
et je crois que c'est vraiment un
élément décisif sur lequel il faudra
être attentif dans cette campagne des
législatives et sur le long terme pour
reconstruire une vision politique qui
correspondent vraiment au clivage dans
notre pays a besoin parce que la
démocratie se nourrit de ce dialogue ce
qui l'image
vous êtes aussi professeur de
philosophie et vous l'avez mentionné
donc plutôt tournés vers ces questions
d'éducation ce sera au coeur de vos
propositions de votre programme pour
cette élection législative vraiment au
coeur parce que je crois que nous sommes
là devant un sujet majeur pour l'avenir
de notre pays et nous sommes là devant
un sujet de justice profondément et
voyez ça c'est quelque chose qui échappe
à tous les clivages tous les français
aspire profondément avoir leurs enfants
recevoir les mêmes chances de réussir et
les mêmes chances d'accomplir leur
propre excellence est aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous avons un système
scolaire dans la faillite signe une
forme d'inégalité très profonde alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer dans ce
système aujourd'hui de l'éducation en
france
je crois que ce qu'il faut changer en
profondeur c'est la vision qui anime
notre école on a vu pendant les cinq ans
qui se sont déployés de ce dernier
quinquennat la faillite complète d'une
vision éducative qui a pour but de
remplacer la transmission des savoirs
par une succession d'activités pratiques
par lesquelles les élèves sont censés
produire leurs propres compétences je
crois qu'il faut revenir à une école qui
enseigne qui donne à chacun les éléments
fondamentaux de la culture et la culture
est la condition de l'accomplissement
pour chaque personne de sa propre vie
c'est donc aussi une condition
fondamentale de la construction de notre
société pour demain mais c'est cette
confiance dans la culture qu'il faut je
crois profondément retrouver et là aussi
j'espère justement pouvoir faire sortir
ce débat des éternels clivage où il a
été enfermé c'est ce que j'ai fait avec
un livre qui s'appelle les déshérités
justement en prenant fait et cause pour
tous les déshérités que notre système
laisse derrière lui
aujourd'hui je voudrais me faire
humblement leur porte parole dans cette
campagne qui commence ça veut dire plus
de moyens pour l'éducation plus
d'enseignants aussi ça fait partie des
différentes discussions pendant la
campagne des présidentielles
je crois qu'on serait trop
on serait trop court en s'arrêtant à une
question de moyens aujourd'hui
l'éducation nationale est le premier
budget de l'état l'éducation nationale
dépense plus comparativement aux autres
pays par élève que d'autres pays qui
réussissent mieux que nous la question
n'est donc pas seulement une question de
moyens bien sûr il ya un travail à faire
sur la réaffectation des moyens puisque
sur leur augmentation
mais la vraie question qui se pose je
crois en profondeur c'est la question du
sens même de l'école de sciences de
l'éducation
nous avons vécu peut-être pendant
plusieurs décennies avec une forme de
passion de la déconstruction avec l'idée
qu'il fallait défaire les élèves de
l'autorité éducative
au contraire je crois qu'il est
nécessaire de la reconstruire de la
refonder non pas au détriment de la
liberté mais au service bien sûr de leur
liberté on parle de l'éducation plus
globalement quel programme pour les
républicains que qui vous soutiennent
pour ce pour cette campagne législative
quel programme parce que je vous avait
reconnu que françois fillon ne s'était
peut-être pas tu étais pas adresser au
plus grand nombre donc il va falloir
faire des corrections dans le programme
qui était présenté pour la
présidentielle aujourd'hui vers quelles
tendances et quel programme il va
falloir développer parce qu'une fois de
plus au sein des républicains il ya
différentes sonorités
ce qui est vrai c'est que on pourra tous
accordés là aussi je pense sur le fait
que la campagne de françois fillon a
d'abord été paralysé par les affaires
qui ont entouré les derniers mois
beaucoup plus que par la ligne politique
qu'il défend des mais c'est vrai aussi
que il faut que nous sachions
reconnaître les défauts de cette ligne
politique et peut-être la compléter je
le disais tout à l'heure en montrant et
en témoignant plus d'attention plus de
social aux plus fragiles aux plus
vulnérables
je sais déjà que les républicains ont
décidé par exemple de ne pas procéder à
une à une une hausse de la tva comme
cela était prévu en tous les cas pas
dans l'immédiat pour prendre le temps de
la réflexion je sais aussi que la
diminution de cinq cent mille postes de
fonctionnaires qui est maintenue va se
faire sur un temps plus long en tous les
cas c'est ce qui a été décidé par par le
par le parti parce que ce que je crois
aussi profondément c'est que malgré tout
il faut porter ce projet politique qui
était celui de françois fillon en le
complétant en l'amendant mais il faut le
porter parce que il a eu la légitimité
extraordinaire que lui a donné cette
primaire la primaire de la droite et du
centre a été l'occasion d'un très beau
débat elle a été l'occasion justement
d'une confrontation très loyal de vision
politique qui se sont exprimés et les
quatre millions d'électeurs qui sont
venus voter ont donné une vraie
légitimité à
jean politique aujourd'hui les électeurs
ne nous comprendraient pas si nous
donnions le sentiment d'une espèce
d'incohérences après avoir défendu ce
projet pendant la campagne
présidentielle
en changeant subitement de ligne de
projet ce serait je crois tout à fait
maladroit ce ne serait pas rendre
service à la qualité du débat
démocratique et donc nous devons je
crois restés fidèles à nous mêmes et
cohérent tout en essayant d'écouter ce
qui peut-être n'a pas marché une
dernière question très rapidement en un
mot est ce que vous êtes confiant pour
cette législative notamment au regard du
résultat du premier tour françois fillon
était arrivé largement en tête 45 % sur
la ville de versailles
même si la première circonscription
englobe aussi guyancourt et
montigny-le-bretonneux est ce que vous
êtes confiant il ya la question des
résultats chez vrai que sur la
circonscription global avec montigné
guyancourt françois fillon et emmanuel
macron font jeu égal donc donc il ya
aujourd'hui une vraie ouverture en
quelque sorte je serais très heureux de
travailler avec beaucoup d'énergie à
montigny à guyancourt on a déjà commencé
à travailler avec tous les élus j'ai
déjà commencé d'aller sur le terrain où
l'accueil est vraiment très bon ce qui
compte pour moi
indépendamment du résultat c'est la
qualité du débat on a été tellement
profondément frustré par cette campagne
présidentielle que ce que je voudrais
faire dans cette campagne c'est
seulement trop posé de façon positive
constructive intelligente un projet pour
la france qui j'espère demain
rencontrera une majorité et vous
viendrez en plateau pour ce débat
puisqu'il sera organisé sur cette
première circonscription comme sur les
autres aussi du département des yvelines
sur notre plateau dans les prochaines
semaines merci françois la première
circonscription pour la 10ème à présent
circonscription le président du parti
chrétien démocrate jean frédéric poisson
a va tenter de conserver à son poste
l'ancien candidat à la primaire de la
droite pour la présidentielle est
soutenue par les républicains sa
présentation est signée nicolas landry à
54 ans jean frédéric poisson se lance à
la conquête de sa troisième législature
avec l'étendard du parti chrétien
démocrate depuis 1995 à travers ses
mandats locaux à rambouillet les
rambouillet territoire il cultive son
engagement politique autour de la
préoccupation de la dignité humaine déjà
préfiguré dans le milieu associatif
l'enseignement public et le secteur
privé mais pas seulement
j'ai été confronté au chômage de longue
durée de mon père
ce qui la détruit humainement donc j'en
ai conçu une vision des rapports
économiques et des relations économiques
qui est pas très libérale je n'ai pas
beaucoup la force des logiques de marché
et la domination des puissances de
l'argent dans le temps d'économies dans
l'entreprise son slogan de campagne pour
cette élection législative pour l'amour
de la france c'est la volonté de faire
que la france soit à la fois redevienne
le grand pays qu'elle est qu'elle
retrouve toute la place qu'elle doit
avoir dans le concert international et
le concert des nations que effectivement
là où il ya des contraintes et où il
faut des contraintes avec elles soient
précises mais on sent bien que les
français ont besoin d'oxygène
autre thématique d'engagement la lutte
contre le terrorisme président du
rapport d' enquête sur les moyens de
déchets contrôleurs de la mise en oeuvre
de l'état d'urgence durant la dernière
législature
il veut mettre en avant la problématique
du fait religieux dans la société
je pense que la question d'un dialogue
avec un islam raisonnée et pacifique est
nécessaire et que la froide la france ne
fera pas l'économie de ce dialogue
un certain nombre d'entre eux doivent
être rejetés combattu condamné sans
aucune espèce
comment dire de faiblesse l'immense
majorité d'entre eux ne demandent qu'une
chose c'est de vivre leur foi
tranquillement dans un espace qui soit
pacifié il faut les aider à cela face à
l'incertitude sur la future assemblée
nationale et la possibilité de ne pas
avoir de majorité claire jean frédéric
poisson défend une conception
transpartisane de son rôle de député la
responsabilité d'un parlementaire c'est
d'abord d'être soucieux de l'intérêt
général
et si jamais ça doit dépasser ses
frontières
eh bien les frontières des partis ou des
groupes pas d'importance face à lui dans
la 10e circonscription des yvelines jean
frédéric poisson aura françois le hôte
du front national jean claude husson du
parti socialiste ou encore le centriste
gilles schmitt cette liste des candidats
n'étant pas définitive et lui aussi sera
candidat dans la 10ème circonscription
david julien bonjour bonjour
représentants des écologistes investi
par europe écologie les verts sur cette
10e circonscription je le disais qu'ils
couvrent parmi les grandes communes
rambouillet maurepas à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ou encore
montfort l'amaury est ce que le député
en place jean frédéric poisson est
aujourd'hui votre principal adversaire
notre principal adversaire aujourd'hui
ce sont surtout les programmes et les
valeurs qui sont totalement contraires
aux nôtres défendu par par ce député par
la droite
on vient d'entendre dans votre reportage
notamment que jean frédéric poisson et
d'autres souhaitent une recomposition de
la droite autour d'un pôle que je
qualifierais de national réactionnaire
et effectivement ce sont toutes ces
idées qui ne nous semble absolument pas
correspondre à l'intérêt général à la
défense des biens communs et à la
construction d'une société d'avenir qui
se transforme profondément que nous nous
souhaitons mettre en place donc
effectivement notre principal adversaire
ce sera bien entendu le projet delà de
la droite de la déconstruction sociale
et sociétale qui nous promettent si
jamais il arrive à nouveau avoir une
majorité à l'assemblée dans les idées
dans les yvelines
néanmoins vous ne portez pas une
candidature commune de
la gauche pourquoi il n'ya pas d'union
avec le ps avec le pcf la france un
soumise par exemple alors cette alliance
est union nous on l'a on la souhaite de
toutes nos forces nous y travaillons le
dépôt des candidatures sera ouvert
uniquement la semaine prochaine ce sera
le 19 des contacts des contrats qui sont
toujours en cours parce qu'il vous aura
pas échappé évidemment que nos valeurs
et nos programmes se recoupe très
largement autour de la question de la
transition écologique delà de la société
de la défense des droits des
travailleurs des salariés des acquis
sociaux et évidemment la construction
d'une république plus démocratique plus
tourné vers les citoyens vers une
sixième république donc toutes ces
valeurs communes
j'espère que nous réussirons allez allez
porter des échanges continuent à avoir
lieu avec les représentants de la de la
france insoumis ça veut dire évidemment
il ya motivé votre candidature
ça veut dire que les compagnons du
retour de votre candidature c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui des discussions honte
honte encore lieu je suis incapable
aujourd'hui de vous dire dans quelle
configuration on sera en capacité de se
présenter
en tout cas moi ce que je constate sur
le terrain tous les jours puisque je
suis élu local directement en prise avec
l'ensemble des gens de ma
circonscription c'est que cette union
cette alliance des gens qui portent le
même projet progressiste écologiste et
humaniste est très attendu et j'espère
j'espère qu'on arrivera à dépasser les
quelques blocages qui sont des blocages
nationaux d'affichage et de principes
qu'ils correspondent absolument pas à ce
qu'on vit sur le sur le terrain et je
pense que si on réussit à dépasser ces
petits obstacles
on suscitera un vrai engouement et une
véritable adhésion et moi c'est ça que
j'ai envie de porter comme message en
tant que candidat aujourd'hui aux
législatives vous êtes conseiller
municipal à rambouillet dans
l'opposition conseillers communautaires
également sur l'agglomération
rambouillet territoire vous avez exprimé
au cours de la campagne présidentielle
votre position sur les différents
projets d' emmanuel macron le nouveau
président élu et vous n'êtes clairement
pas dans l'idée de rejoindre une
majorité présidentielle par la suite si
vous êtes effectivement pas dans cette
optique tout simplement parce que le
projet d' emmanuel macron ne
correspondent pas aux grands objectifs
que je vous ai lister les planeurs ya
des points très précis par exemple à la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation vous
n'êtes pas favorable je suis
effectivement pas favorable à la manière
dont emmanuel macron entend modifier
même supprimer la taxe d'habitation pour
deux raisons c'est que si on supprime
cet impôt local premièrement on retire
des mains des communes et donc des élus
locaux qui connaissent le terrain
un outil de pilotage de leur territoire
or aujourd'hui on voit que les
territoires en tout cas sur la 10e
circonscription
les territoires les plus les plus ruraux
se sentent déjà abandonnés parce que les
services publics disparaissent parce que
l'offre de transport est malmené parce
que on voit une désertification médicale
grandissante
si en plus on retire de la main des élus
locaux la capacité à faire les choses et
ce qu'ils entendent sur le terrain on
risque d'avoir un rejet est un sentiment
d'abandon et un déclassement encore
exacerbée donc ça c'est un premier gros
problème et puis deuxièmement la manière
dont emmanuel macron entend supprimer
purement et simplement la taxe
d'habitation ne correspond pas non plus
à sa transformation de manière juste
indexé notamment sur les revenus des
ménages sur la composition des des
foyers et c'est ça que moi j'ai plutôt
envie de mettre en place
si on supprime la taxe d'habitation ça
veut dire qu'on la remplace par autre
chose on la remplace notamment par des
recettes fiscales qui vont directement à
l'état par exemple la principale c'est
la tva qu'elle l'impôt le plus injuste
qui existent en france donc supprimer un
impôt local qui a tous ses défauts mais
qui peut être intéressant pour des pieds
des politiques territoriales adapter le
remplacer par un impôt
vraiment injuste je trouve ça totalement
totalement déplacé donc là on parle de
choix au niveau national il ya aussi une
défense toujours pour un député de son
territoire quels sont les les points
importants sur cette 10e circonscription
aujourd'hui que je pense que le point le
plus important sur la 10e
circonscription c'est l'aménagement du
territoire et le rééquilibrage de
l'ensemble des politiques territoriales
on est sur un territoire qui et péri
urbain qui est juste à la sortie de la
métropole parisienne et je pense que une
des grandes missions du député de la
députée qui sera élu dans quelques
semaines ce sera devrait à ce que
l'égalité territoriale soit au coeur des
politiques menées sur sur le sud sur le
sud yvelines
il ya des territoires des communes qui
sont un peu délaissé aujourd'hui ça veut
dire que l'ensemble des communes du sud
yvelines souffrent de troubles et de
mots qui viennent d'une vision de
l'aménagement du territoire qui
correspond tout à fait à celle qui est
porté par emmanuel macron qui parle de
compétitivité qui parle de productivité
qui dit compétitivité des compétitions
compétition entre d'élite et les
territoires qui veut dire segmentation
fonctionnelle des territoires et on se
retrouve avec des personnes dans le sud
yvelines qui doivent se déplacer qui
font trois heures de transport tous les
jours avec une offre de transport je le
disais qui est dégradée avec des
services publics qui disparaissent des
bureaux de poste qui sont en danger des
offres de transport qui sont pas adaptés
le service médical l'hôpital de
rambouillet
je souhaite porter ce combat de manière
très forte partie des travaux si vous
avez soutenu
absolument et voilà ça c'est un des
grands piliers la le rééquilibrage des
biens et des services sur l'ensemble du
territoire est évidemment la
préservation de notre environnement de
notre cadre de vie sur lequel auquel
nous sommes extrêmement attachés dans le
sud yvelines lutter contre toute cette
expansion urbaine qui suit les grands
axes on voit bien sur la n10 1 qui
traverse saint quentin qui file sur le
sur le sud il y avait hier par un
franchement avec le 92 par exemple parce
que là aussi vous êtes exprimés 78 91
pâtisserie mais de manière très claire
de manière tout à fait opposé à ce
projet qui veut simplement donner selon
les termes mêmes de philippe devedjian
et pierre bédier incidents des
hauts-de-seine 11h une profondeur
territoriale hauts-de-seine en se
servant des yvelines comme c'est comme
c'est bien dit pour couvrir en réalité
une suite de grands projets inutiles
extrêmement coûteux injuste et
destructeur bien entendu notre
environnement notre cadre de vie des
bretelles d'autoroutes des ponts des
ports multimodaux etc
c'est pas du tout la vision apaisée de
notre territoire et que je souhaite
porter en tant que candidat à la
députation et c'est pas du tout non plus
la halle attente très forte des
yvelinois dei niçoise qui souhaitent
préserver leur environnement leur cadre
de vie et en profiter sont servir des
grands projets financiers d'urbanisation
merci d'être venus en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes candidat dans la
10e circonscription pour les écologistes
investi par europe ecologie les verts
même si bien évidemment la liste
définitive des différents candidats sur
votre circonscription et sur les autres
ce sera pour le 19 mai date de fin des
dépôts des candidatures en préfecture
merci à vous nous avons ce 7,8 politique
prochaine édition
le 17 mais d'ici là la campagne est bien
sûr à suivre est également dans nos
différentes éditions quotidiennes du
journal l'intégralité des replays a
consultés sur notre site internet et sur
notre application mobile à très bientôt
sur t&d fils
[Musique]